同学们好啊，今天上23课。
23克了已经哎，其实22课就是昨天才。
上线了，然后今天就录23课了，为啥这次更新那么快呢？之前隔了一个多月呢。
是因为昨天的课程上去之后呢。
有同学发弹幕说我瘦了，被你们发现了是吧？
我这个月减了嗯算一下啊。
这个月减了12斤。
一个月瘦了12斤，为啥呢？
是因为我之前有一刻我好像打过一个比方。
我训斥某些同学。
嗯，就是没有信心的那些同学说哎呀，我们能不能学会编剧呀，好像看起来好难啊，然后我就训斥他们，我说学任何东西啊。
都像减肥。
他的方法就摆在那儿。
对吧你说难吗？也难，很多人减不了。
你说真的难吗？也不难，因为方法你知道，只是你不愿意坚持。
对吧你只要愿意坚持啊，就能做到学编剧就是这么回事儿。
他就想减肥，你愿意坚持一定能减。
但是马上就有同学问我。
老师，那你怎么这么胖呢？
嘿呵呵嘿嘿。
呵呵。
，问的我哑口无言是吧？减肥的方法我知道吗？我知道胖吗？确实也胖。
我知道瘦好还是画好呢？我当然也知道瘦脸肯定好，不管是形象上呀。
还是健康上呀，都是瘦点好。
然后就我觉得对吧？I'm a teacher啊，我得为人师表呀。
我既然跟同学们说，你只要想做到的事就一定能做到。那我首先就。
对吧我先做的。
您。
22克跟21克之间正好隔了一个月嘛。
那一个月时间。
我减了12斤。
是吧。
然后昨天22课更新了之后啊，同学们发现我瘦了，心情好，今天再录一节课，再讲一节课。
哎，我是咋减的呢？啊，其实减肥就是我说的就是特简单。
就是管住嘴，迈开腿，就从这两个方面下手。第一呢嗯。
就是少吃碳水，对吧？碳水肯定要少吃。
所谓的碳水就是精致碳水啊，少吃，就是米饭、面条、馒头这种少吃。
碳水这个东西吧。
人是需要的。
但是呢精碳水这个东西就说粮食这个东西吧。
他本身发明出来的时候就不是特别善意。
具体呢我就不想在咱们的课上说了，因为这种都属于引战的话题，对吧？你像张文红就张文红医生，他他他他他说那个。
少喝白米粥对吧？因为对健康不好啊都有人喷他说他这个。
崇洋媚外什么的，所以我就不多说了，但是粮食这个东西呢确实是。
哎呀，咋说呢？你有条件的话，你就少吃，可以吃粗粮，但是精粮呢少吃，因为精粮真的。
从客观来说，我们从生物的角度，从化学的角度，咱们用科学的态度严谨的说，它确实就是把好东西已经剔除了，留下的就是淀粉，也就是糖分。
然后呢给你冲击。
确保你活着。
这么简单说吧，所以这个啊就这咱就不说这个东西了啊，就是说我我这一个月减肥啊，首先碳水我没吃。
或者说是尽量没吃吧，有时候加班没办法，对吧？公司这个同事点了披萨，点了饺子，咱咱也吃是吧？就是尽量少吃控制碳水。然后呢。
多吃。
肉。
多吃蔬菜哎。
最好的就是肉和蔬菜，优质蛋白和蔬菜肉呢就是首选是当然是鱼肉啊、鸡肉呀、牛肉这些对吧？这个猪肉羊肉呢那个那个相对来说吃的少一点。
然后蔬菜呢我也有个秘诀，就是以绿色为主。
但是呢一定要搭配各种颜色，因为蔬菜你去研究里面的营养物质是不是均衡，那个太复杂了。我有个简单方法，我就从颜色分。
我每天买菜你知道吧？绿色肯定是主流。然后呢，比如说哎太绿了，大配点红色，对吧？胡萝卜这个这个番茄。
然后一看哎还可以再搭配点。
这个别的颜色，比如说哎再搞个茄子，对吧？就颜色上去搭配。
然后呢，水果适量。
主要吃蛋白和。
蔬菜其实就是肉和蔬菜，水果呢也要控制。很多人说哎呀。
那我吃水果作为健康吧，我用水果代替饭，我这顿不吃饭了，我吃个西瓜，一个西瓜比你吃饭发胖更多。所以就是。
管住嘴就是这两个方面，我主要吃肉和蔬菜。
嗯，各种颜色的蔬菜，然后呢肉主要吃稍微优质一点的蛋白，就是鱼啊、鸡呀。
然后搭配点牛肉。
嗯。
然后迈开腿呢，就是每天早晨跑一跑呀，或者是蹬一蹬自行车呀，对吧？适量的运动一下。
你如果像我这种就是好多年没有运动过的人，你一下子也不可能说跟人家一样出去跑个10公里8公里，对吧？配速多少多少，你肯定追求不了那个。
你就是把自己的心跳。
调调起来，心肺功能拉起来，对吧？你这个老爷车重新磨磨肛，然后呢出汗。
对吧一定要到出汗的程度，每天呢运动个。
20分钟以上吧。
不管你是蹬自行车也好，还是出去快步走也好。
还是再加这个这个波比跳呀、划船机呀、俯卧撑啊什么的对吧？
就是就是。
动一动，然后这一个月就很有效果。12斤。
当然了，他总归会有瓶颈的时候，再减12斤你就困难了，但我还是会坚持啊还是会坚持。
呃，并不是说一定要跟同学们较劲，说啊，老师说了减肥很容易，我就要减给你们看，不是那个意思，就是为了健康。
就是为了健康好，对吧？心肺功能呀。
你的这个这个。
身体负担呀都会轻很多。
所以呢。
咱今天是第二十三节课，对吧？第二3课的内容就是减肥，怎么就讲到减肥了是吧？扯到减肥了呢？
2三课讲的啥内容呢？
我不是说了嘛？因为心情好啊，因为心情好，所以就讲点。
同学们点播了好久的一个内容，就有很多同学想让我讲这个内容，我一直没讲，为啥呢？是因为这个内容不是那么好讲，没有看起来那么好讲，而且它很严肃。
很严肃的一个内容。
很多同学以为我肯定讲的好。
啥内容呢？
喜剧。
很多同学说，老师，你做了那么多年喜剧，对吧？你肯定对喜剧比较熟悉，你给我们讲讲呗。
不吹牛逼的说，我确实挺熟悉喜剧的，但是呢我也不是那么敢贸然的就给大家讲。
因为喜剧这个东西吧。
他其实很严肃，就这个话题很严肃，这个这门课很严肃，都有专门的喜剧教材。
想当年啊。
上戏还开过喜剧班。
明白这个意思吧？就是有表演班就正常的表演系。当然了，还有什么那个音乐剧班，对吧？表演班，然后什么喜剧班有过真有过，我不知道现在有没有了啊，好像是没有了，但是当年真有过，就喜剧班。
我们当时还讽刺他们呢，可能就是就是考表演系，各方面都达标了。但是某一项没达标，就去了形象没达标，就去了喜剧玩了。我当年还这么开玩笑。
嗯，所以说喜剧啊，它确实是一个。
怎么说呢？
大家都关注的话题，很多同学想让我讲很多同学想让我讲，我感觉他们可能是第一喜欢喜剧的人很多。
第二呢很多人就。
觉得一个东西搞笑幽默呃，肯定是更有卖点。
再有呢很多同学可能比如说他在从事流媒体啊、自媒体啊、vlog呀、短视频啊这些这些工作，他也会觉得哎喜剧更容易传播。所以呢老想让我讲讲喜剧。
今天呢我就给大家讲一讲。
嗯，就是。
还是那句话，以我的理解给大家讲一讲。
因为喜剧啊并没有一个严格的边界和门类。喜剧悲剧的这个这个这个这个玩意儿吧。
这个界限或者是这个区别呀。
有点像阴和阳。
就他其实是。
可以转换的相辅相成的，没有那么明确界限的对吧？所以我只能说。
第一，咱这节课就不要说叫喜剧了，我们叫浅谈喜剧，好吧。
浅谈喜剧省得这个是吧被人喷说咋哎哎呀，你就讲喜剧了，咱们浅谈一下。
这是第一。第二呢。
我把我的理解。
给你们。
同学们一定要有一个自己的知识体系啊，你看咱课上了这么长时间了。
我没有统计过，但是你扒拉一下，咱这个课好像上了好几十个小时了。
好几十个小时，什么概念啊？
就是你如果在大学学的话，你一个学期未必学得完呢，对吧？一个学期未必学得完。
所以它其实已经成为系统了。
同学们如果有认真的听咱的课，你其实应该生长出自己的一套知识体系，一套关于故事，关于剧本的知识体系。
然后呢。
我希望每个人是有自己的体系的，因为每个人的知识基础知识结构不一样，知识储备不一样。你像我。
我是一个。
比较理性的人。
然后呢，我呢小小时候呢比较擅长。
数学。
和物理学。
然后呢我在大学里面呢主修。
经济学呃管理学。
我我我很喜欢经济学管理学，我到现在也一直这个不断的更新经济学的知识。另外我还腐修过心理学。
所以我的知识体系呢。
就是假设你的你的认知是一棵树的话，我的根儿其实是长在。
很理性的一些。
底层知识上的，比如说数学和经济学。
举个简单例子啊。
比如说咱今天去要做一件事情。
或者是需要设计一个桥段。
我们的主角。
设计的一种对抗冲突，然后解决后面一个问题，就是有个因和果的关系，我脑子里面啊不由自主的就会出来成本与收益的。
一种衡量标尺，对吧？我会衡量哎，我这个主角设定。
挺奇怪的。
为什么呢？是因为我为了解决后面一个对抗的问题。
所以前面加了这么一个有点偏生硬的设定。然后这个偏生硬的设定呢，为了让观众接受，我需要给观众。
解释铺垫。
已达到我后面嘎的一下，有一个好的对抗，让观众开心一下的这个诉求。那我就会考虑这个成本和收益的问题，这个收益够不够？
是不是比我们的成本大值不值得做？
解释成本会不会太高？
我就会考虑这个问题，这就说明。
我我的底层逻辑是有很多呃呃经济学的管理学的东西在里面的。
咱们的同学啊，您其实也有你的知识数。
对吧。
你有你的一个理解的底层逻辑。
我呢把我的逻辑给你，你摘过去装在你的树上。
懂吗？我是希望是这样的，最后大家都形成自己的理解，我们来探讨一起探讨对等探讨。
对吧因为你们不是小学生，你们如果是小学生的话，我就在你们的内心哎，我就扑了扑了，哎，噗查着吧，浇点水，松松土，种上个种长棵树，对吧？就就从我的树上摘个果子，一颗种子，我就给你摘栽进去了。因为我知道你那是不是片荒地呀。
对吧就找我这棵树就行，但是你们呢都是大人了，而且还有很多已经是从业者了，你们有一棵自己的树了。所以呢你们从我这儿摘点果子呀什么的，乱七八糟的装点你那棵呃圣诞树，呃是这样的，好吧，所以咱们今天呢就一浅谈喜剧。
第二呢谈的是我的理解。
我给大家这个你自己去选好吧，哪些对你有用？
因为从上节课开始，咱们其实已经开始在讲专题了，讲讲怎么写高潮，对吧？讲讲怎么写喜剧，后面我们还可以专门研究研究台词，专门研究研究呃那个那个那个反派，对吧？专门研究研究这个人物行为，就是这种都属于专题啦。专题这个东西啊。
他就像果子了。
对吧它就不是栽树了，它就像果子，对吧？同学们就是哎选你喜欢的实用，对吧？就像我挑蔬菜一样，你可以根据颜色挑，对吧？根据你的口味挑好吧。
理解了吧，同学们，我们赶紧上课啊，这节课我们谈喜剧。我说喜剧这个东西啊，首先它有点玄的糊的。
它就像阴和阳。
阴阳啊对吧？喜剧和悲剧。
他没有那么大的界限。
那我们也试着来探讨一下喜剧的定义，好吧，就啥是喜剧。
我们说喜剧的定义。
喜剧的定义啊。
很多人喜欢翻。
古典的东西说你看啊最早啊人家莎士比亚对喜剧是有个定义的，亚里士多德的喜剧有是有个定义的。谁谁谁对喜剧呃，鲁迅还有个定义呢，是不是？
嗯。
我在这里强调一下我的观点。首先聚这个东西它本身就是个舶赖体。
外国来的对吧？然后那喜剧就更是一个舶来品。所以我们可以理解外国人为何如此去定义它。
因为它有源头，他当时是那样的，但是我们还要知道这个东西啊，剧这个东西它最早是在舞台上，现在是在电视上大荧幕上，在手机里，对吧？它肯定是有发展变化的，我们一定要有这个概念啊。
那我们就看一看大家对喜剧都有过什么样的定义。
比如说亚里士多德这祖宗级的，他怎么。
定义喜剧呢。
嗯，我们描述一下打概意思啊，具体装逼的话，你们如果想复述的很完善的话，你自己去搜啊。
他说。
喜剧就是模仿。
那些不如我们的人。
喜剧就是模仿描绘那些不如我们的人。
比如说一个聪明人去演一个傻子。
这就是喜剧，他为啥这么定义呢？因为在那个年代啊，舞台上的喜剧其实是滑稽剧，就滑稽戏，就上来一个人演滑稽，明白我意思吧？就是正常大家在了个很严肃的在排戏的时候，电场啊或者空档啊，上来一个人耍宝。
滑稽那滑稽如何引人发酵呢？它其实主要就是模仿。
那些明显不如我们的人。
所以亚里士多德有这个定义。
叫。
模仿。
明显不如我们的那些人。
然后鲁迅也有个定义，也值得我们探讨。鲁迅说。
悲剧是摧毁那些有价值的东西。
喜剧是摧毁那些没价值的东西。
也有一定道理。
从某个角度去理解的话，也有一定道理。摧毁有价值的不就是悲剧吗？你就难过吗？摧毁没有价值的，你不就图一乐嘛，对吧？没有价值的把那个炮着扣在一个破锅里，然后点上赶紧跑嘣那个锅炸了。那个锅本来也是个破锅没有用。然后所有人呢哈笑，为什么？
摧毁了一个没价值的东西，小孩放炮炸冰窟窿什么的对吧？最后一个没有价值的东西，从某些角度理解。
也是对的。
然后我记得我在直播的时候，还是不知道干什么的时候，有人问我喜剧和悲剧的区别的时候，我当时也给了一个定义。
我说。
悲剧。
是主体的悲剧。
观众站在主体的角度。
喜剧是主体的悲剧。
观众站在了客题的角度。
这个定义啥意思呢？
就是。
本质都是悲剧。
有句话不是说过吗？喜剧的内核是悲剧吗？
他内核都是悲剧，只不过一种你感同身受了。
你跟他一块难受。另外一种呢，你看笑话了。
是吧看他笑话了。
看他出丑，看他笑话，看他难过。
这就是喜剧。
听起来很残酷。
但也是一种理解方式。
更重要的是什么呢？
我通过这个定义，潜移默化的把我跟亚里士多德，还有鲁迅并立。
开玩笑啊，这也是一种理解方式。
其实就像啥啊。
你看啊这几个说法其实不矛盾的，模仿一个明显不如你的人，或者是摧毁一个没有价值的东西。哎，鲁迅说的这个摧毁没有价值的东西，实际上是你认为没有价值呀。
你客体认为没有价值啊，你怎么没有去问问人家主体的难不难受？那个破锅他会觉得自己没有价值吗？
你把那个破锅给炸炸烂了。
那你有没有考过考虑过锅的感受或者锅的主人的感受呢？
对吧你凭什么认为人家没有价值呢？所以说这个东西啊其实是说不清楚的。
但是几种定义其实本质上啊是可以。
都一样的啊，没有必要去较真儿说哪种对哪种错。
还有人说，那喜剧其实就是优越感俯视。
俯视一切，你把观众放在俯视的角度，你看下面几个傻瓜，对吧？在那耍宝，怎么这么傻，这么蠢啊？明知道前面有个坑，为什么还是要掉进去呢？你不就是在俯视吗？就是优越感吗？
哎，这这这也是一种一种说法。我曾经在之前的课上啊打过一个比方，我说喜剧啊。
本质。
有时候特别简单，也很残酷。
比如说。
下雨天下大雨，突然下大雨，瓢泼大雨，对吧？马路上人都赶紧躲雨，没带伞，没想到嘛，然后呢，你坐在房间里，你淋不草雨，你看着窗外。
大家都在赶紧找地方躲雨，在那跑，突然跑过来一个胖子。
很胖很胖。
摔了个狗吃屎。
我跟大家讲，90%以上的几率。
我们都会笑。
真的一定会笑的。
这其实就是喜剧的本质。
为什么呢？
第一，你没在雨里。第二，你不是胖子。
什么情况下不笑呢？你跟你一个哥们一块砍，你哥们儿。
跟他一样胖，你还好意思笑吗？
对吧你如果你哥们儿是个瘦子，你们俩肯定一排大的个干那个的死胖子，对吧？
但如果他是个胖子，或者你是个胖子。
你还笑得出来吗？
笑不出来。
叫了出来。
所以说这其实就是喜剧的本质。
或者是说。
是它原始的样貌。
笑。
对吧一定程度上的嘲笑吧。
那你说你去看，比如说卓别林的那些。
电影卓边电影就是华把滑稽戏搬上了电影屏银幕嘛。
他演一个很傻的人，或者是很。
很小的小人物，很可怜的人，很倒霉的人，你在那笑。
严格说，那不就是嘲笑吗？
看滑稽嘛，看他出洋相。
所以关于喜剧的定义。
我也没有明确的定义，但是我把刚才这些东西。
讲给你了，你自己摘你想听的，想要的你拿去。
好吧，讲到这个喜剧和悲剧的。
区别问题这个这个这个。
相当于阴阳嘛，顺便说一下，喜剧悲剧是有歧士链的。
对吧你看喜剧演员很难拿表演表演类的奖项，明显的喜剧电影很难得。
大奖。
为啥？
就是有这个歧视链，人们啊。
看喜剧的时候。
开心不开心？
开行。
但是呢你内心深处潜世里面，其实知道你是在嘲笑别人。
所以呢。
喜剧就有点像什么呢？
你想爽一下的时候，你去找人家，对吧？登大雅之堂的时候呢，你就不带人家了。
哎，就是这样，就这个情况，见不得人夜胡对吧？见不得人就这样。
可能也与出生有关系。因为早期我们说舞台上是正儿八经在那儿演剧，到喜剧阶段呢就电个场搞滑稽。
所以喜剧悲剧还有这个骑士链。
这里呢咱就不不过多去讨论了啊，因为很多喜剧大师跳出来，那就不爽呀，说让人笑比让人哭难多啦，对吧？那个在那争吵，这个东西没有必要没有必要，因为本身是也不应该说出现说。
什么演员就一定是喜剧演员，对吧？你像范伟。
范伟老师，你说他是喜剧演员吗？
他是他当然是这个这个这个彪哥要匣子是吧？多少经典形象呢？
那个那个演技炉火纯青，对吧？
范伟老师，我觉得在中国。
演员里面。
不仅是现代的演员，我觉得在中国影史上也能排进前几。
那是一定的对吧？他的角色范塑造的范围非常之广，而且没有一个掉链子，没有一个掉链子，没有一种他拿不下的。
嗯。
他是喜剧演员。
但他也是悲剧演员，正剧演员。
说到底，那就是演员。
好演员对吧？
所以呢其实链咱就不去过多讨论了啊。
嗯，没有什么难与不难，喜剧和悲剧也没有那么多的界限。
没有那么多的界限。咱们在之前的课上。
有一节讲过斯奈德。
类型片儿的分法10种故事，对吧？10个故事类型。
没有喜剧。
记得啊没有喜剧。
所以说呢。
喜剧的还不是一种片儿，实际上或者是说不是一种故事类型。
它更像是一种。
风格。
一种元素。
对吧或者是一种。
另外一种衡量体系。所以说喜剧片啊不是我们写故事的时候。
想的故事类型那一挂，它是另外一种划分体系。
周星驰不是说嘛，对吧？很多人都说哇，周星驰你。
这个这个这个这个喜剧大师拍那么多喜剧片，你怎么那么会搞笑啊？那个周星驰为每次都怎么回答？周星驰说搞笑了吗？我没有搞笑呀。
我就是想拍一个人的故事啊，他很努力想要踢球啊。
或者他很努力想要。
成为一个。
人上人啊，他很努力想要追求自己的爱情啊。
他就是说他没有想写喜剧，对吧？所以说他也不承认，他或者说他也不愿意承认。
他在拍喜剧片或者是这种片子，你要喜剧片去定义他。
所以喜剧片啊更多的是一种元素，是一种风格。
就说。
我们还说斯奈德的那分分类方式啊，可以有一个喜剧的金羊毛片吧。
可以有一个喜剧的愚者成功嘛。
可以有一个喜剧的。
英雄片吧。
喜剧的爱情片吧。
都可以有。
所以说呢它是另外一种体系。
咱今天呢就给大家讲一讲。
你如何？
把你的片子搞成喜剧片，或者是写一个喜剧片。
但是跟斯耐德那套体系不冲突，你还是该写你的故事类型啊，写你的故事类型。只不过在这个类型上，我们。
叫。
叠加上喜剧吧，好不好？就在你的原本的故事类型上叠加上喜剧。
叠加上戏剧。
我们有一个叠加的概念。
好吧，叠加了感这节课我们就。
好好研究一下研究一下。
那叠加这个喜剧呢，我们就不能从类型节拍的角度叠加了，我们得往后退。
往回倒退一下，倒退到我们最初讲故事的时候。
的要素。
故事要素那里。
人物事件主题呀。
股市要素的里贺看。
首先，人物。
我们说你的片子如果要有喜剧属性，或者是是被称为喜剧片，让别人笑，对吧？
人物肯定是你首先下手的地方。
喜剧人物嘛，我们经常讲喜剧人物呀，金凯丽一出来对吧？因那个表情一做，他演一个警察也好，演一个那个那个还演过那么主播播音员，他不管演什么，他就是个喜剧人物呀。
对吧喜剧人物如何塑造？也就是说你这个片子里面你的人物哎呀，身上有喜感，喜剧人物，那你肯定就。
就就就可以归为喜剧片了嘛，就肯定可以让人笑了。比如说你的片子有岳云鹏，有宋小宝是？明显就是个喜剧片了嘛。
就得给他创造喜剧人物呀。
对吧。
那就我们来研究一下喜剧人物的创造。我们说人物。
分。
身份。
欲望。
和动作。
我们还是从这几个方面去逐一分析如何塑造写剧人物。
我们说啊喜剧人物啊。
从总的来说啊，我刚才说过。
要让人造成一种俯视感。
让观众有一种俯视感，对吧？
俯视感俯视感呢。
有两个方法。
就有两种角色你会俯视他。
第一，那肯定就是小人物嘛。
小喽残对吧？残残缺残疾，对吧？你去看乡村爱情对吧？你俯视你的人物。
一般有两种情况，一种呢就是这个人物小呃，笼统来说就是小小人物嘛。
然后还有一种呢。
不合理。
一个明显不合理的人物也会让你服视的。
也会让你服视的。所以说人物这里总体上来说是这个原则，是让观众服视你的人物。
瞧不上他，或者对你的哎呀呀呀，我这呀呀一目了然，对吧？了然于胸，不会仰视的呀。
仰视你怎么怎么去搞笑呢？那个那个呃下雨天你在街边有个小卖部，你坐在里边，小卖部呢淋不着雨，突然下雨了都没伞。然后一个胖子找地方躲雨，穿这个拖鞋，然后呱唧摔那儿了，拖鞋拖鞋都是那个。
摔到腿从脚上套在腿腿腿脖子上了，你能不笑吗？
你肯定笑，为啥呢？你服视他。
然后呢，这胖子过去之后又过来一个胖子，这个胖子呢呃那个那个呃。
坐在一辆加长的劳斯莱斯里，司机开着车，然后呢。
下雨呢也没关系啊，人家在车里还星空点，对吧？然后人家摇下窗。
看看你朝路边吐了口痰，你笑得出来吗？
你笑不出来的呀，为啥就腐视不了他呀，又腐视不了他呀。我在劳斯莱斯里呀，对吧？腐视不了他，所以说创造喜剧人物主要是营造这个俯视，两种方法要么小要么不合理。然后呢来剖析一下，从要素的角度都可以有哪些具体的招。
先从身份身份这里对啊，不合理不就可以用了吗？
不合理呀。
不合理不合理。我们其实在课上也讲过了。
就是加一个含有附加值的定语。
对吧。
他不适合干这个事儿啊。
那么在喜剧里面，这个不合理就可以放大。
在证据里面呢，比如说。
我们这个不合理。
一个老师。
去做老师。
那他可能不够格做老师。
不够格做老师呢，他有可能是悬疑的不够格，有可能是恐怖的不够格，他要杀小孩啊，对吧？那在喜剧片里面这个不合理，就是说这个含有附加值的定语，明显不称职的这个定语，那肯定就是往搞笑的方向做了一个不识字的老师。
全都要靠蒙是吧？干啥都要靠蒙。那马大帅马大帅不是开了个学校当校长嘛？然后他不就是个文盲嘛？然后教同学语文的时候。
他啥成语也不会，他整节课都在提问，就是全是啊这个关于这个成语来，你你起来说什么意思啊，这小孩说完了之后，他还无从判断对错，然后又叫一个小。那你说他说对不对？然后这小孩再回答一下，然后他还要再保险下，再确认一下嗯。
来，你再说一下他俩到底谁说的对，再确认一下是吧？这就是身份上呃不合理。
其实也就是我们之前说过的，还有附加值的定语，只不过这个附加值呢我往搞校里做好吧，这是身份上第一个。也就是说你这个。
还有附加值的定语呢？
可以反差很大。在喜剧里面啊。
反差可更大反差可更大。
另外呢身份这里呢。
加标签。
也是一个。
常用的招数。
比如说美剧里面喜欢加这个家伙是一个书呆子，他们的常用标签，对吧？然后过去的那个老的喜剧里面也还有常用的标签，这个家伙是个守财奴，特别抠。
对吧一个人特别抠，哎，他有了这个标签以后，你后面搞喜剧也会容易很多。那你就让他花钱呗，对吧？你就坑他花钱呗，只是这个标签儿。
也是一个重要的，在身份证里啊，也是一个重要手法，一个怕老婆的人，气味人啊，这也是一个标签，对吧？也是一个标签。
这种呢也很常用啊，标签。
还有呢在身份这里呢。
还有其实还有更外化的东西，就是把这个标签外化，或者是把把这个这个其他的东西外化。就是我之前说过的。
比如说有明显的残缺。
对吧这个你看。
我们说嗯赵老师赵本山老师。
在很多电影里面客串的时候都是斗鸡眼。
你有没有发现这个问题？就是因为他经常客串什么捕快呀，这个警察呀来那一个捕快，一个警察。
其实是需要你有。
观察力。
需要你有观察力、判断力。
有一定的敏锐度的对吧？你像那个那个那个福尔摩斯通过各种细节就能看出各种线索，他呢就做一个附加值的定义。
就是我啥也看不出来。
啥也看不出来呢？因为他呃经常客串是客串，他怕你get不到他这个点，他就把它外化出来，直接外化成斗鸡眼。
直接外化成斗鸡眼。
是吧，这就是。
做一些外化的特征，也可以营造喜剧。然后人物的第二方面，我们说欲望。
欲望。
还是遵从人物塑造的。
这两个原则。
不是呀不合理这。
没有。
简单一句话说。
就是癞蛤蟆，想吃天鹅肉啊。
癞蛤蟆想吃天鹅肉啊。
这就是喜剧片里面的欲望。
为啥？因为你这个角色是个癞蛤嘛，首先这个身份就定了定死了，他是个癞蛤蟆，他还想吃千鹅肉。
你作为一个正常的人，一个客体，一个观众。
坐在你的小卖部里避雨，你能不服侍他吗？
你还想吃天鹅肉，对吧？
这就是从欲望层面。
就我们这个人啊从身份上你已经给他塑造完了。
他有明显的不合理，他也有标签了，也有外化特征了。然后呢再让他想吃天鹅肉。
啊，就是喜剧片。
他一旦想吃天鹅肉之后，他会做出很多。
荒诞的选择。
不合理的选择。
为我们的观众啊提供笑量。
然后从动作的角度呢。
我们说动作动作本身是啥呢？
动作是人物在压力之下做出的选择和行为嘛。
因为我们说一个故事啊，如何成为一个故事啊，其实是你的主角在压力之下产生的。
绝不是他的日常，日常的是纪录片，不管是大人物、小人物，啥人物，你塑造啥人物。你所讲给别人的这一段故事，这个剧本它本质上是主角在压力下在非常态状况下做出的。
新的选择或者是激发潜力的一种选择，或者是找回真我的一种选择，这是所有剧本故事的本质。
就是你塑造的人物在压力状态下。
或者说在干扰状态下，在激励状态下做出的新选择。
新行为。
超出他的日常了，这才叫故事。日常呢就记账了，对吧？那这个动作。
我们说对于一个喜剧来说。
他做出什么样的动作呢？
我们说在。
我讲人物的那一课里啊，我在这里我还给大家打过比，方，举过好多例子，我说这个动作要获得观众的许可。
获得观众的认可。
在这里其实就是反的。
本质上观众是不认可的。
因为你做出的是一个明显错误的选择。
明显错误的选择。但是呢你做出一个明显错误的选择。
你又不想失去观众。
喜剧片本质也是一个故事呀，它也是一个影视作品呀，它也是要卖钱让观众看的呀。
你不可能说我为了创造喜剧，我他妈这人物你也看不懂，欲望也是呃慌枪走板，动作观众完全不认可。
就让观众看傻逼。
那也不行。
所以说啊有些喜剧演员这么说，有些喜剧演员说喜剧更高级，更难做。
他也是基于这一点，就是我既要让你跟着我走，我还要让你笑。
这个其实是有点难的，确实在这个层面上来讲啊是有点难的。就是你看啊我让观众不认可我的动作，但我还不能让观众离场，不能让观众抛弃我。
所以呢。
咱这么说吧。
其实观众是啥心态啊？观众不认可你这个动作，但是呢觉得你这个傻逼做出这种选择呢也合理。
对不对？所以说本质上是这样，他本质上是不认可的。
因为他认为他比你高级。
他会做出更好的选择。但是你做出这个选择了之后呢？
他忍了。
他也忍了。
我给大家举几个例子啊。
比如说。
嗯。